[Musique]
dans la campagne d'oka à l'ouest de
montréal la nouvelle serre de
l'entreprise les jardins de la pinède
est opérationnel depuis quelques
semaines elle a une superficie de 52 rue
1000 pieds carrés et huit variétés de
légumes qui sont actuellement cultivés
on a besoin d'un climat tropical pour
faire pousser des aubergines challenge
degrés marie-josée daguerre vendée pagny
bio depuis six ans et compte aujourd'hui
800 clients qui pour la plupart
n'achetez rien en hiver grâce à la serre
elle pense maintenant atteindre 1000
abonnés et elle pourra leur offrir des
produits variés à l'année longue les
gens veulent vraiment connaître la
provenance de ligue 1 ils veulent avoir
aussi un produit de qualité et un
premier bon au goût tous nos plans sont
en plein sol donc ont produit plusieurs
variétés dans la serre on a vraiment là
je dirais la cadillac présentement
dessert en bio
une cadillac qui a coûté cher 4 millions
de dollars mais la moitié a été payée
grâce à des subventions de québec si on
n'avait pas eu ces subventions en pleine
période de pandémie on n'aurait pas pu
construire le complexe
son entreprise fait partie des 200
projets de serre qui ont été financés
par le ministère de l'agriculture depuis
un an le mapaq fin 2020 s'était donné
comme objectif de doubler les 123
hectares de cultures serricole du québec
d'ici cinq ans en 2021 40 % de
l'objectif a déjà été atteint soit une
superficie équivalente à tout le parc
olympique de montréal dans encore un
frein 140 150 projections temps analyse
le pays enfin 14 mois qu'on a lancé la
stratégie alors pour moi là la réponse
est là l'effervescence et leur milieu et
au gaz et les trois quarts des nouveaux
projets permettront à de petits
agriculteurs de prolonger leur saison de
quelques mois l'autre cas visera une
production à l'année
industries harnois dans lanaudière est
un des plus gros fabricant de serres en
amérique
160 personnes travaillent ici son pdg
patrice harnois souligne que les clients
divers sont moins nombreux mais leurs
commandes plus importantes les cultures
qu'ils veulent exploiter détermine le
type de serre fourni on a toujours une
bonne demande croissante et
l'actionnement on travaille beaucoup
beaucoup sur le futur ce moteur de
nouveaux projets potentiels et légumes
de base comme cette tomate et hausser sa
demeure populaire je pourrais plus en
plus bâton c'est du déguisement faye
c'est des légumes et fines herbes des
choses plus un peu plus spécialisés
clientes des industries harnois
l'entreprise ferme d'hiver est en train
d'agrandir à vaudreuil dorion surprise
quand on entre dans ses installations
des murs de fraises pour 6,6
l'agriculture verticale permet
d'optimiser la production la fraise
offre la capacité de produire en bonne
quantité et de vendre avec une maj
suffisamment grande pour justifier la
mise en place de plusieurs fermes ça va
marcher la ferme divers si le maraîcher
qui fait de l'argent
les marges de profits déjà petit en
agriculture sont réduites en hiver en
raison des coûts énergétiques élevés
pour chauffer les serres les fermes
d'hiver a développé une technologie pour
diminuer les goûts de ses lumières del
alors dans la salle ici on a
l'équivalent de 700 kilos at qui est
grosso modo 700 plaintes chauffante
qu'on aurait la maison chez nous donc il
ferait très très très très chaud il
fallait gérer la chaleur
les lumières sont refroidis à l'eau mais
leur chaleur est captée et dirigé vers
la sphère adjacentes utilisé par un
maraîcher local pour l'aca édition
pourra dire qu'on soit 20 90% l'eau
qu'on n'utilise plus encore dans nos
camps d'électricité donc c'est
d'électricité a souhaité christique sens
pour les lumières qu'on récupère la
chaleur puis on chauffe la salle avec se
produire à l'année mais ça nous permet
d'avoir un revenu plus stable tout
l'année ça nous permet de garder des
employés à l'année aussi ferme divers
qui a signé un contrat avec les
supermarchés iga pour vendre ses fraises
à des prix concurrentiels en hiver
annoncera bientôt un nouveau projet pour
décupler sa production on importe 133
millions de kg par année de frei ce fait
même si on va en chercher mais
trahissent millions de kilos ce qu'on
essaie de faire dans les trois quatre
prochaines années ça c'est quand même
juste 10% cru des importations les
ventes on serre ont totalisé 4 103
millions de dollars au québec en 2020 le
chiffre est en constante progression
d'augmenter leur notre autonomie
alimentaire saviez
territoire
andrée lamontagne demande aux québécois
d'acheter douche dollars de plus
d'aliments du québec chaque semaine ce
qui effectuera un milliard de dollars
dans l'économie de la province this is
it jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
bon rien